مقطع فيديو جديد بين إسرائيل وحماس
يُظهر المدنيين الذين يبحثون عن الطعام في
غزة، واليأس هناك، حيث
يحتشد الناس بشاحنتين يتسلقون تلك
الشاحنات وهم يحملون مساعدات إغاثة في
الجزء الشمالي من غزة الذي لم يشهد سوى
القليل من المساعدات التي وصلت إلى
هنا جميعًا  من هذا، حذر الجيش الإسرائيلي
المدنيين من إخلاء أجزاء
من وسط غزة على الفور، بما في ذلك
مخيم اللاجئين بالقرب من وادي غزة،
وقالت وزارة الصحة التي تسيطر عليها وزارة الصحة إن
الغارات الجوية الإسرائيلية قتلت ما لا يقل عن 50
شخصًا في جميع أنحاء القطاع في وقت سابق
اليوم، في هذه الأثناء
يتزايد الضغط  ويطالب مسؤولو البيت الأبيض إسرائيل منذ أسابيع بتقليص
القتال وإعادة الرهائن المتبقين،
ويضغط مسؤولو البيت الأبيض على إسرائيل
لتنفيذ مرحلة مستهدفة في حربها
مع حماس تتضمن استئناف
مفاوضات الرهائن.